I'm an artist and an engineer a lily
I've been thinking a lot about how
technology mediates the way we perceive
reality and it's being done in a supreme
visible and nuanced way technology is
designed to shape her sense of reality
by masking itself as the actual
experience of the world as a result we
are becoming unconscious and unaware
that is happening at all take the
glasses I usually wear for example this
had become part of the way I ordinarily
experience my surroundings I barely
notice them even though they are
constantly framing reality for me the
technology I am talking about is
designed to do the same thing change
what we see and think but go unnoticed
now the only time I do notice my glasses
is when something happen to tell my
attention to it like when it gets dirty
or my prescription changes so I ask
myself as an artist
what kind of crate to draw the same kind
of attention to the waste digital media
like news organizations social media
platforms advertising's and search
engines are shaping our reality so I
created a series of perceptual machines
to help us d familiarize and question
the waves will see the road for example
nowadays many of us have these candles
allergic reaction to ideas that are
different from ours we may not even
realize that we've developed this
channels mental allergy so I created
helmets that creates this artificial
allergy to the color red it simulates
this hypersensitivity by making
bad things look bigger when you're
wearing it it has two modes
nocebo and placebo in a civil mode it
creates this sensorial experience of
hyper allergy
whenever you see red the red expanse
it's similar to social medias
amplification effects like when you look
into something bothers you you tend to
stick with like many people and exchange
messages and memes and it would become
even more angry sometimes a trivial
discussion gets amplified and blown way
out of proportion
maybe that's even why we are living in
the politics of anger in placebo mode
it's an artificial cure for this allergy
whenever you see red the red shrinks
it's a palliative like in digital media
when you encounter people with different
opinions we will unfollow them remove
them completely out of your feet it
cures this allergy by avoiding it but
this way of intentionally ignoring
opposing ideas makes human community
hyper fragmented and separated the
device inside the helmet reshapes
reality and projecting to your eyes
through a set of lenses to create an
augmented reality I picked the color red
because it's intense and emotional it
has high visibility and is political so
what if we take a look at the last
American presidential election map
through the helmet you can see that it
doesn't matter if you're democrat or
republican because the mediation alters
our perceptions the allergy exists on
both sides in digital media what we see
every day is often mediated but it's
also very nuanced if we are not aware of
this we will keep being vulnerable to
many kinds of mental allergies our
perception is not only part of our
identities but in digital media it's
also part of the value chain
our visual field is packed with so much
information that our perception has
become a commodity with real estate
value designs are used to exploit our
unconscious biases algorithms favorite
content that reaffirms our opinions so
that every little corner of our field of
view is being colonized to sell at like
when this little red dot comes out in
your notifications it grows and expands
and your mind it's huge so I start to
think of ways to put a little dirt or
change alysus of my glasses and came out
with another project I keep in mind this
is our conceptual it's not a real
product it's a web browser plug-in that
could help us to notice the things that
we would usually you know like the
helmet the plug-in reshapes reality but
this time directly into the digital
media itself if shout out the hidden
filtered voices what you should be
noticing now will be bigger and vibrant
like hear this story about gender bias
emerging from the sea of cats the
plug-in could dilute the things are dead
are being amplified by an algorithm like
here in this comment section there are
lots of people shouting about the same
opinions the plug-in makes their
comments super small so now the amount
of the amount of pixel presence they
have on the screen it's proportional to
the actual value they are contributing
to the conversation
[Applause]
[Music]
the plug-in also shows the real-estate
value of our visual field and how much
or of our perception is being
commoditized different from ad blockers
for area as you see on the webpage it
shows the amount of money you should be
earning we're leaving the battlefield
between reality and commercial
distributed reality so the next version
of the plug-in could stripe away that
commercial reality and show you things
as they really are well you can imagine
how many directions disco really go and
believe me I know the races are high if
this were to become a real product and I
created this with good intentions to
train our perception and eliminate
biases but the same approach could be
used with bad intentions like forcing
citizens to install a plugin like that
to control the public narrative it's
challenging to make it fairer and
personal without it just becoming
another layer of mediation so what does
all this mean for us
even though technology is creating these
isolations we could use it to make the
world connected again by breaking the
existing model and go beyond it by
exploring how we interface with these
technologies we could step out of our
habitual almost machine-like behavior
and finally find common grounds between
each other technology is now a neutral
it provides the context and frames of
reality is part of the problem and part
of the solution we could use it to
uncover our blend spots and retrain our
perception and consequently choose how
we see each other thank you
thank you
[Music]